welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Avengers infinity war left us
with infinite heartbreak both its ending
and it's heroes even after the countless
times I've Doctor Strange through this
thing this infinity saga rewatch has
turned up a whole bunch of new stuff
that I somehow missed let's get started
with a new breakdown of this movie with
the opening words the word director
Kenneth Branagh cameos as this voice and
if you think about it this film actually
bookends with the distress call from
another director director Nick Fury
welcome haffley as guardians did escape
this attack including Valkyrie Korg and
me we know arrived at new Asgard an
endgame but you can actually see them
fleeing here in the grandmasters
pleasure craft from thor ragnarok Thanos
preaches I know what it's like to lose
Co so desperately that you're right yet
to fail nonetheless turns the legs to
jelly you talk too much
at 29 minutes Thanos has the most screen
time of any character in this film the
war by comparison has only half that 14
and a half minutes the framing here
reflects that disparity with the
Avengers so small and defeated that we
initially don't even recognize him at
Thanos his feet
the writers framed Thanos as the true
protagonist of this story it's his
journey making the war structurally his
antagonist like head Thor gone for the
head he'd be the Euro of infinity war
instead he's this movie's crazy ax
murderer also that idea of failure
turning the legs to jelly dark and cap
wobble off their feet at the end of this
movie and when Thanos fails in endgame
he's all jelly to Loki calls back Tony
and Avengers we have the hawk
we have a Hulk Thanos defeats Hulk
deliberately not using the power stone
it's the last we're seen of Conqueror
Thanos he now removes his armor retiring
to a spiritual quest josh brolin based
his performance on Marlon Brando in
Apocalypse Now both of them
delusional baldies actually stubble is
visible on Thanos his head it's
suggesting that like Brando he shaves it
out of similar dogmatic commitment evany
ma says my
personage vows before your brandy yeah
we get it he's a boss but he's actually
directly quoting Mephisto Thanos's
right-hand demon in the Infinity
Gauntlet comics he's yet to make an
appearance in the MCU other than a
barely readable line back in Avengers
Loki's death is preceded with his memory
of Odin's recent death an acknowledgment
of him as a son I Sons I've been waiting
for you
i Loki Prince of Asgard rode in son he
even turns to the left with the same
training an expression he'll never turn
again because his you know his neck did
this until he shows up in a different
timeline and Loki thanks to the time
heist with the same thing that he just
died for I used to think infinity war
was a story of sacrifice and to be fair
it is we don't trade lives but on a
deeper level Loki and Heimdall shocking
early deaths here established this as a
movie about mourning how do we accept
the deaths of loved ones what kind of
monster would think that watching a
loved one die would make things better
in any way well Thanos that's who now
Thanos is a psycho Malthusian
eco-terrorist and he's wrong on so many
levels but the Avengers stubborn refusal
to let any of them die ever that's naive
so yeah in this movie they're taught a
brutal lesson in triage sometimes you
just gotta let go so that we can all
move forward it's not evil that's just
like human existence it's an awesome
dark lesson to which the Avengers say
[Music]
using Captain Marvel and quantum ground
[ __ ] an end game actually Tommy and
I will answer all your quantum realm
questions in the next episode of the big
question check it out now hoax Bifrost
trajectory takes him past the Sun first
then past the moon to earth there's a
redditor who charted this out to propose
that there was a solar eclipse at this
moment which ancient Norse peoples
interpreted as a sign of the coming
Ragnarok apocalypse and had this diagram
pasted the eclipse over Norway as it
would need to be for that prophecy to be
true Hulk's vector would have landed him
on the eastern seaboard so maybe there's
something to this banner of course lands
in the sanctum with his warning as
Silver Surfer doesn't comics notice the
cloak of levitation wraps around
strange later banner appears to be
wearing some strangest casual clothes
poor guy always just needs to borrow
some clothes Tony tells pepper about his
vivid dream of their kid named Morgan a
dream that comes true an end game but
only after his haunting nightmare of
Earth's doom from age of Ultron comes to
pass Tony Vickers was strange did you
seriously just say hither 200m seriously
leaning up knowledge of the cosmos never
next one the comics strange uses the
cauldron of the cosmos to help
spider-man look backwards in time as
strange as cryptic one plan will require
the Avengers to do they mentioned making
balloon animals with just a nod to dr.
Strange's jimmy kimmel bits also been in
Cherry's ice cream flavor a hunka-hunka
burning fudge which Banner eats in
endgame
Tony pulls out the old flip phone cap
FedEx to Tony stank and Civil War that
2011 18 to 21 days envelope icon means
that there is an unopened text here
indicating that cap must have text Tony
something on this phone that he never
read wouldn't been another text anyone
else had this number maybe it was a
check-in on mission since cap and its
crew was tailing him to keep an eye on
him Peter Parker's spidey sense triggers
his arm hairs just like the tiny hairs
real-life spiders used to send fibration
sorry pet spiders scared you he takes
off from Stanley's school bus wearing a
shirt reading let's just the taste of
sadness and he'll get a big mouthful of
lettuce as this movie ends Tony's new
mark 50 nanotech armor absorbs his
sunglasses as he takes them off meaning
that they could have just absorbed it
around his face he just took him off as
an intimidating tactic evany mob burns
his hand on the eye of agamotto just
like that Raiders not see with a
headpiece and when Wong severs Culp
Citians hand on the other side of that
portal Bruce Banner had his fists up
ready to go
Tony shoots up to st. Peter inside to
his helmet you can see his nanotech
preparing to assemble into that foot
booster later on and tighten that does
the same thing you can see the nanobots
prepping into the missiles that he's
about to fire at Thanos but here this
foot booster was an upgrade after Tony's
failure to catch up to Rudy in the Civil
War
lose never forget the guardians of the
galaxy sing along to rubberband man a
song written for the spinners producers
son to cheer him up for being teased
about his weight and if you think about
this song would be on yondu's Zune and
in the next scene quill hits fat-shamed
so this is his real daddy cheering up
that kid who to him it was always small
I'm good for thievin panteth by the way
is always hilarious to watch in the
background of these movies after Peter
tells them to put on their mean faces
you can see her practising Nash super
teeth for several minutes and later on
in nowhere she creeps in with her hands
and fingers folded downward like a
praying mantis when Thor grabs Gamora
shoulder she reaches for her sword
instinctively that swords got Slayer by
the way to slay this god if she needs to
however she wants to wanda scans visions
mind stone visually foreshadowing the
way she'll last this thing out of his
head later just fili you that line also
foreshadowing visions final words to her
I just feel you that saves them he is
torn off the star emblem from his suit
because he's now a man without a country
the Nomad version of himself well not
exactly but you get it and through the
tears on a suit underneath cap is still
wearing older scale armor natasha has
gone blonde and wears this gray vest
same one that yalena Bulova is wearing
and puts the upcoming Black Widow so I
think we can assume it'll shed light on
Nets two-year period between Civil War
and now and why she's probably killed
her friend and took her top and her hair
color in nowhere one of the collections
of the background is a blue man an awed
by the Russos to their work on Arrested
Development it's also worth noting that
this intact version of the bolt is
actually a reality stone illusion
Michael so Thanos conjured this blue man
from his own imagination in another
reality stone clue that fan spotted a
couple years ago when the blue ray came
out when Gamora stabs Thanos and pulls a
dagger back that dagger doesn't have any
Atlantis's blood on it back in Avengers
HQ stephen mcfeely co-writer the movie
cameos is one of secretary Ross's aides
invision makes his most useful
contribution to the MCU Tanis threatens
off the universe
one life cannot stand in the way of
defeating it but it should we don't
trade lives yes
the adventures could have just skipped
ahead two visions faint ripping out that
USB Drive without exporting it but
there's stubbornness to like surgically
go around and try to sustain his soul
gives Thanos just enough time to get the
time stone and then reverse all this
their refusal to trade lives costs
everyone everything and it will force
them to trade lives nonetheless into
Warren
evany mod tortures Doctor Strange they
were originally designed for my
procedure cruel irony restrained whose
pre sorcerer days were spent doing micro
surgery like this and recently the
writers revealed an alternate version of
the scene where Tony saves strange by
putting him in the mark 50 nanotech
armor strange tells them if it comes to
saving you or the kid or the time stone
I'm not hesitate to let either of you
die yeah finally someone is speaking
some sense the other Avengers losses of
loved ones and mentors felt like
avoidable mistakes to them every battle
since they've been trying to fix what
they thought they did wrong but strange
lost the ancient one and she taught him
that death gives life meaning
so yeah strange is totally willing to
sacrifice others also sacrifice the time
stone itself because he knows it could
lead to a winning in the game have
rewatching a great movie like this makes
me appreciate the filmmaking process and
its impact on great attention to detail
and now is a better time than ever to
take a class and learn more about this
craft which if you do with skill share
thanks to skill share for sponsoring
this video skills share is an online
learning community that offers
membership with meaning so much to
explore real projects to create and the
support of fellow creatives Skillshare
empowers you to accomplish real growth
deal share offers classes designed for
real life you can learn and grow with
short classes that fit any schedule
skills shared lets you explore classes
that may help you express what you're
feeling inside right now with creative
self-discovery taking a creative writing
class or a painting class a Photoshop
class those can help you break up the
routine especially if you're spending a
lot of your time indoors they have
classes and topics new rock stars fans
will enjoy like animation film video
music production class that I checked
out that I really liked is teach
yourself to draw anything a step by step
process taught by hate and hope the
class focuses on building a routine of
drawing so that you can prove your
skills over time I am now the best
drawer of all time of
dick Figures but I'm getting there
sculpture is curated specifically for
learning there's no ads and they're
always launching new premium classes so
that you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you and
it's less than ten dollars a month with
an annual subscription the first 1,000
of my subscribers to click the link in
the description will get a two month
free trial of premium memberships that
you can explore your creativity with
Skillshare vanos uses both the power
stone and the space stone to separate
nebulous parts and torture each part of
her which would be double the amount of
pain that he gave Thor with just the
power stone earlier he tells Gamora I
never told you to lie that's why you're
so bad at it yes in guardians volume 2
nebula also was unable to lie you know
you'd think an evil supervillain would
learn how to properly lie and an endgame
she echos Thanos his whole lying policy
my father has many things
liars not Thor rocket and Groot find the
ruins of middle ear in a tree who forged
the Infinity Gauntlet with a mold the
screenwriters recently interpreted that
the gauntlet Thanos had in the age of
Ultron post-credit scene was a practice
gauntlet and thank God because that
clears up actually it makes things a lot
more confusing because now we have four
gauntlets but they assemble a new weapon
in theory it could even summon the
Bifrost did have a name Stormbreaker
Stormbreaker is the name of the battle
ax beta ray bill carries there in his
time is Thor and yes it does have
buy/price powers you can notice how this
mold is engraved with the symbol of the
Bifrost that it scorches into the ground
strange cushions a crash landing for
Tony and Peter oh you want yes one that
Tony will get strange the one out of 40
million 605 features that they succeed
in and the one sacrifice play that
strange reminds him of in endgame and he
always trembles his hand he also does it
here when confronting the Guardians
and went surrendering the time stone
which I pointed out in the Doctor
Strange breakdown is some really solid
acting continuity by Benedict
Cumberbatch since his hands were never
fully healed the gravity on titan is
reduced
mantas bounces and Drax yawns which
might not just me because he's bored but
because reduce gravity makes the air
thinner resulting in yeah I mean to get
more oxygen
yeah you just gone didn't you
nanostick more encounter you know puts
his hand back to keep gomorrah behind
him a protective instinct setting up his
coming sacrifice of her is even more
heartbreaking also the fact that reticle
identified her as daughter of Thanos
despite him not be her real father he
kidnapped her but it means that he was
still the truest paternal figure to her
soul the analyst his father was others
an eternal rumor has it the upcoming
eternals film might show us a young
Thanos and maybe that history will be
explored further during this whole
sequence Thanos caries gamora's all
things balance dagger in his belt
we only realized that when she snatches
it to try to kill herself but it's
another pose reality stone illusion
meaning he kept it there as a trick to
keep gomorrah on the line thinking she
had a fail-safe to take her own life but
she had to it's one final lesson using
this dagger as a symbol for his whole
dark balance philosophy and I love how
panis is true love tear trickles right
into the trench on his cheek as if this
guy was designed naturally selected to
be the universe's top mortar
T'Challa tells the Black Order Thanos
would have nothing but dust and not yeah
solid foreshadowing Thanos does get his
dust and the blood of those he left
wounded and again that victory comes
from Fanus is willingness to trade lives
killing themselves
Tosh is concerned look signals her dread
she gets it we don't trade lives but
they do they're gonna win the wakandans
chant the war cry that translates to
hold or hold fast and we actually heard
this first in black panther it's the
river tribes call
T'Challa is saluting and paying respects
to his loved Nakia T'Challa
in cap lead the charge they both have
enhanced speed but T'Challa is a step
ahead
the last time they sprinted in a scene
together one was chasing the other it's
civil war now they run together side by
side cat on his left a tree smashes a
storm breaker molds meaning this weapon
could never be forged again now this
molten arrow also appears to flow into a
second Forge which at first I thought
was for the back half of the hammer but
you can see both pieces are beside each
other in that one mold
maybe it's the missing handle but that
wood
be a weird thing to also make out of
guru I'm just pointing out a tree might
be using the company printer ink for
personal projects along the blade of the
edge of Stormbreaker Asgardian runes
translate to loose the dogs of war
a famous paraphrase from Julius Caesar
cry havoc and let slip the dogs war
Groot winces as his branches singe cuts
off his arm or the handle so Groot like
strange gets that personal sacrifice is
key to victory and now anytime Thor
swings Stormbreaker group will be by his
side the three ride the Bifrost ooh
Wakanda rallying the others notice
Rudy's war machine armor is now marked
for an upgrade after his mark 3 well you
know on Titan Thanos begins to use the
stones in interesting combinations so he
uses the power stone to blast through
Tony's debris and then the reality stone
to turn it into bats and then he
combines the power stone and the space
stone to harness fire from Tony's
explosives and then redirect it as a
flamethrower
he stops quill Drax and nebula with the
power stone when we cut back to him his
soul stone is weirdly glowing maybe he
spared gomorrah's soul here I don't see
why he'd want to do that maybe he needed
to combine with the soul stone since
quill is a half celestial quill uses as
gravity snare on Thanos the same device
he used to hook the Power Stone Orban
guardians vol 1 using it again years to
regain stone possession but thanks to
quell they fail and feyo's uses another
stone combination the power stone to
smash up a nearby moon into chunks and
in the space stone to spike all the
chunks down atom we come back to a condo
rocket again shows his obsession with
spare body parts and banner uses his
handy Hulkbuster arm to clamp out a call
obsidian stump from his severed arm
earlier blasting him off to his death
and vision also comes full circle and
his killing of Corvus glaive surprise
impaling him with the same weapon an
attack he used on him back in Edinburgh
now the writer said that they based a
nose and Strange's wizard duel on the
Vincent Price Boris Karloff duel in the
Raven strange tries to trap the notes on
the mirror dimension Thanos turns it
into a black hole strange turns that
enough butterflies a sweeter version of
the Thanos bat spell earlier the writers
also reveal that strange was originally
going to drag fan o's into a vision of
the bones of his victims and a trial
with the Living Tribunal judging him
guilty strange uses is in
of icons fell from the comics but Thanos
sees the soul stone again to identify
which strange was a real one Tony and
Thanos his fight echoes Tony's past foes
in reverse order so he has a thruster
powered hook like his shotgun armor
against Killian and Iron Man 3
this cuts Thanos know that true drop of
blood echoing Iron Man 2 with Flash's
line if you could make God bleed people
will cease to believe in him and after
stabbing Tony Baldy tilts over paralyzed
Tony just like Baldy oh but I stain did
in the first Iron Man and Wakanda cap
briefly holds back the nose Brolin
includes a subtle look of surprise and
respect Thor blinded by vengeance
surrenders the hero title to Thanos
because victory would have been his
neither seemed a little higher gone for
the head who loved Thor's no I get any
crazy antagonist in a movie the moment
they get defeated
danos portals away in a couple years
back I pointed out how you could see a
green glow on that wound suggesting he
might be using the time stone to reverse
the injury but you watching it there's
also some red in there to suggest that
he could be using the reality stone to
also work the wound really all the
stones are glowing and you can see all
six of those colors in the wound
suggesting that it takes all six tones
combined the shakeout storm breaker and
the dusting begins the VFX artist
settled on desaturated dust to connect
with these spiritual ashes ashes dust to
dust concept but also to make it easy
for the particles to blend in and
disappear in the background so it's not
just like clumps and piles of ash it's
dust scattered amongst the soil and God
James Gunn later tweeted that groups
final I am Groot to Rocket translates to
dad Wanda throws her head back in
anguish her last thoughts being her
murdered love untighten Dave Bautista
delivers this heartbreakingly
high-pitched well as his final word and
Peter spidey sense gets one last
devastating news sensing the oncoming
pain did you start
I don't feel so good afterward Tony
looks at his hand and he holds it to his
face as if trying to embrace that dust
that just slipped through his fingers on
his garden barn
Thanos watches the Sun Rise just as he
promised earlier and then what I finally
rest watched the Sun Rise on a grateful
universe a God resting on the seventh
day in the corner his armor hangs as a
scarecrow
just like farmer Danis in the comics
everyone ends this movie on their butts
The Avengers feel the sting of the lives
they fought so hard to never have to
trade but now nevertheless dead in their
hands but Thanos also feels that pain of
sacrifice didn't cost him but he wins
because he faces the morning join our
next MC watch long on discord by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
new rock stars follow me on instagram
and twitter at EA boss following rock
stars and to hit that subscribe button
because shrunken little boy Scott Lang
can't we check
[Music]
boom you looking for this